if you're having a hard time trying to
find the perfect business idea for
yourself or trying to make more money
from the one that you're ready came up
with I'm going to share with you a clip
from Donald Trump that I think will help
in your book the art of the deal you
said that money really isn't that
important it's just a means of keeping
score it's playing the game that excites
you I love the game I like the money and
the money is certainly a method of
keeping score but I don't do things for
money I do things because I enjoy doing
them that really sometimes can translate
into more money than you would have made
if you went just after the money the way
I like to summarize this is you have to
make big decisions with your heart and
the small ones with your head this is
one of the biggest mistakes that most
entrepreneurs make this is a reason why
80% of new businesses will fail and it's
mostly because entrepreneurs jump in
start a business because they think they
can make a lot of money and end up
failing look at this YouTube channel as
an example I started this YouTube
channel thinking with my heart right
because I I wanted to create video to
help other entrepreneurs I learned
through video and I wanted to have a
channel that I knew could help other
entrepreneurs so that's a heart decision
the next heart decision was the type of
content that I put up I loved profiling
famous entrepreneurs I wanted to share
things that inspired me I wanted to
answer people's questions and that was
all from heart right I still put things
up that I believe in that I love
regardless of how well it will do in
terms of views and traffic I put it up
because I feel like it's important then
I'll get to the smaller decisions the
head decisions which will be things like
how do I name this video what title do I
put in what description what tags what a
playlist do I need to add this to to
help give it the maximum exposure and
reach more people so the head logical
decisions are still there but they're
buried under a whole bunch of heart
decisions where most entrepreneurs will
do the opposite they'll start with the
head they'll look logically to see what
industry is making a lot of money
now and how can I get in there and
maximize my chance of being successful
as well and they look at a list of the
top 50 businesses to start right now to
start earning extra income and number
one might be flipping homes so they jump
into flipping homes without knowing
anything about the industry and having
zero passion for it and for those of you
in the business you know how hard
flipping homes is and you see the people
that come into the industry and leave
just as quickly because they've lost
their shirt starting the business with
your head is the fastest way to lose
money because you're not passionate
about what you're doing so big decisions
always in business or in life with the
heart and small decisions with the head
believe thank you guys so much for
watching I love to know what you think
about the Donald Trump clip if you want
to leave a comment underneath I'd also
love to hear your thoughts on thinking
with the heart versus with the head if
you want to leave a comment I'm gonna
join in the discussion if you like this
video and you want to see more don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
to the newsletter thank you so much for
watching have a great day and I'll see
you soon what am I talking about lost my
train of thought the way it like this
summarize this is you look mm-hmm the
way I like to summarize this is you Wow
the way the way the way the way the way
the way oh well that's not even what I
was saying I'm back I'm back and I'm
ready